♪♪
We are here to celebrate
Selena Gomez, tonight
because of this really thoughtful
and courageous
and quite frankly
brilliant documentary film and
we are going to do it here at
the historic Apple Tower Theatre
in Downtown Los Angeles.
And we are going to do it with
You and the fans and Selena
Please welcome, Selena Gomez.
Thanks, guys.
I love you.
it is a different kind of
Applause, I think, it feels
different. Don't you think?
I do. I think people have seen my
diary so I'm like.
It is always so supportive,
like, we love you.
It is great to see you.
This is cool, what a great
location for us to
Be able to hang out and talk.
Thank you so much for being
here, this is beautiful.
I wanted to start by asking
the most obvious human question
that we should start every
conversation with, which is, how
are you?
I do not know, actually.
It has been weird.
The documentary exists and it is
Out and it has been six years in
the making, I have moments where
I am relieved and moments where
I cannot believe it is out.
Is it a good thing, a bad thing?
I think I will always have these
this internal struggle of figuring
out if I am doing the right thing.
And it has been validating so far
that I am doing something good.
and that means the world to me.
I know you have not been actively
Reading the critical reviews.
And why would you, I mean how do you
read a review of your life?
That is strange.
But the reviews are in.
Right?
Thanks.
and rightfully so.
This film is just brilliant.
We are going to get into it.
I made you a promise a week ago
when we spoke that we would try
and have fun because I think
there is probably a desire from
people who have seen the
documentary to ask a lot of questions
about what you went through and
I can imagine that is the
reason you made that
documentary to not have to
answer those questions again and
again.
Essentially, yeah.
But that does leads me to the
question, why did you make this
documentary, from your
perspective?
I think originally, I thought
I was going to make a
traditional tour documentary
about my music and about the
Revival tour.
And, as I recognized my mental
state at the time I look back at
that girl and I do not even
recognize her anymore.
It broke my heart to see myself
talking about my body and how it
needed to look a certain way.
I just felt really bad.
I had to cancel that tour.
That was the first tour I had to
cancel.
After 55 shows you had really
put the time in already.
That most people's just for the record
That's most people's full world tours, 55 shows.
We were in the middle.
And it was really hard because I
never ever want to let anyone
down.
I always want to show up for
people.
But I knew I could not keep
going.
I had to stop.
Then I picked it back up again
and we started to film my trip
to Kenya and we thought maybe we could do a
short about this adventure that
we are going on and this
experience.
Then I had to go straight to
London and Paris and I quickly
realize that all of this stuff
that is going on in my life, it
all started with me.
How am I feeling?
how am I navigating through all of these
different things that are going on
in my life how am I surviving
and
ultimately, it is going to be a
story about my mental health
journey, it is not going to be
necessarily a puff piece it is
going to show every part of me
and that's the good the bad the ugly
and the real.
I think great documentaries aren't so much reactive
I think a lot of them can be that way
react on periods of life and try to retell that story
in an entertaining way that is great to watch.
But great documentary films are proactive.
And when I watch them, I feel like
the subject is learning about themselves.
and going on a journey.
The documentary is guiding that process more
than you are guiding the documentary.
Did it feel that way, would you
have pushed forward the way that
you did?
I think so, I would like to
believe, that Alec, and I had a relationship where
even in the weakest moments when I had a lupus flareup,
and it was really painful.
he would ask me a few times
if I was comfortable being recorded.
I thought, I want to be able to
show people all of it, so just
go ahead.
That is weird to say, but it also
felt like a big relief because I
know I am not the only one that
is hurting that way.
It should be talked about, and
it should be seen.
But, what about when you saw
it? It’s done thing to be living it and experiencing it,
you have this trust with the camera already in life
to some degree and understand
its role but when you look
back at the footage, edited or otherwise
it is got to be tough for you.
It’s tough for me, it’s tough for us.
I have only actually seen it all the
way through one time.
I, I can’t. I do not think I could
watch it again.
Did you watch that, basically, like almost for
approval? Like I can let this go now?
I was there for parts of
editing, I could see transitions
and I knew how the story would
be told.
when it was all put together it
was really hard, it affected me for a
couple of days afterwards.
and I realized that was not where I
was anymore and I did not need
to revisit it.
That’s a beautiful realization that as well
to realize that you have come so far.
I know what you mean when you feel sad
when you recognize, somebody who is yourself,
going through so much pain.
its a reflection of the work that you
have done since then, but it
is kind of bittersweet. You feel for that person.
It’s like you have a relationship with yourself.
It’s kind of crazy.
It is a little weird to be learning, by no means do I have life
figured out in any way shape or form
I just have a better
relationship with my mind.
None of us will, that is the
point.
No.
I do, genuinely, hope to start a
relationship with my mind, and
my mental health that I will
continue to grow and I will continue
to understand more and more.
Alec was the director who was behind
the camera who else did you need to forget
that was there.
There were multiple people.
We kind of picked up and stopped
filming, people were shooting
other things.
There is a list of names I would
have to give you.
That is a huge amount of
trust.
It is interesting, the age of
seven, it is very unique, I
wonder how you recognize that
relationship between you and the
camera.
Something that captures you.
Well, I think it’s different because
I started as an actress
first, having a relationship
with the camera and having
it be invisible is just naturally
part of it.
I love being on sets, I love
doing shows and films.
I thrive in that setting.
You actually want the camera to
fall in love with the character
you are creating. So I love that.
Then the flipside is I am walking out
of the hospital and there are 12
photographers screaming and wanting
a bad angle, a bad picture, to say
I’m not doing well or I’m in rehab and then you’re just
hit with that awareness of cameras.
That can throw you off
completely.
It obviously became unhealthy.
I have had to had have
different relationships with how
it works, even in music videos
it is different than being
on set.
I probably prefer being on set.
Of course, that is a part of why you did this
because of that false narrative you’ve
had to exist with throughout your life.
This idea that you have lived
multiple lives, there is where
you are at any given moment and
what we see and the story they
choose to tell.
That is not reality, that is not
the narrative, this film is.
Was that a motivation for doing
this, did you want people to see
it once and for all?
Somebody asked me if I shared
so much that people are going to
want more, what is more?
I think I've stayed -- I think I
have said it all.
But I totally appreciated that
question.
It is The ending of this movie,
is me right here and now.
I want to talk about tools
and where it began, for you to
work on yourself.
There is an interesting scene in
the film where you described
being terrified of thunderstorms
as a kid.
When I first got out, I did
not know how I would cope with
my diagnosis.
What if it happened again?
What if next time, I did not
come back.
I needed to keep learning about
it, I needed to take it day by
day.
When I was a kid, I was
terrified of thunderstorms.
I grew up in Texas and I was so
scared that lightning and
thunder would mean a tornado is
coming.
But I learned that storms mean
lightning and thunder and the
more I learned about it the less
afraid I would be it really
helped.
[applause]
That feels like, to me, the
beginning of self-help.
Would you trace it back to that?
Yes.
I 1000% would have to give my
mom credit for that.
I felt so scared of so many
things in life, because I
felt anxious, that I needed to
be the best that I could be.
My mom was the person who
allowed me to be the person I
wanted to be, did not judge me,
and loved me through it
and would give me the information and tools for me
to grow.
Instead of instilling more fear
in me she educated me on the
things I was terrified of, and
she would give me that strength.
That is interesting, it is
how you apply it to your life,
and how it works for you.
What works for you?
You know I love yoga, there’s certain things
I know that if I don’t do them…
I’m not good at yoga.  That’s for damn sure.
I didn’t say I was good at it, but it
definitely works for me. What works for you?
It is the little things, I
just had COVID, I thought, here
it comes. I was gonna get a little
depressed and go down a spiral.
I immediately recognize the
little things that I needed to
do to get out of it.
I decided to change the things
that I was watching to things
that were well-written and
beautiful and happy, I changed
the music I was listening to, I
wanted to listen to positive
things and be inspired.
It's something like taking a walk, calling a
therapist, calling a sponsor,
all of these things that seem so
minuscule, that you do not think
will work or matter, getting up
and looking at yourself and
being OK with who the person is
on the others.
I love that you mentioned
music, what is on your positive
playlist?
Oh my God, The new album from
Taylor Swift right now.
All of it.
Flawless.
A remarkable body of work.
Do you allow music to keep you
company when you are sad?
1000%.
Essentially, I was raised in a
world where our emotions were
illustrated by music.
My mom grew up listening to
Patsy Cline, and Joni Mitchell,
and Janis Joplin.
My dad grew up listening to
Other music, like Selena Quintanilla.
Who was named after.
He had a flair for R&B.
I was inundated with so many
styles of music.
It was a part of my life.
I was 11 years old listening to
Coldplay or Maroon 5 and
pretending that I was in love
and I was in a breakup in the car.
I would pretend that I felt
these emotions.
You are not pretending, that
is the beauty of it.
I was pretend crying.
When you feel that so vividly
as a kid, and we all feel that
when we love something.
We feel it.
And then If you stay feeling
that, whenever, 10 or 12 years
later, you find yourself doing
what, singing a song with Chris
Martin.
[LAUGHTER]
I did not actually put that
together.
You only get there if you
feel it, there is no pretending.
That is true.
There are incredibly poignant
moments when you come home.
We have seen this before.
We all go home.
It is great.
You were not just going home to
reflect on the experience you
were searching for purpose
there.
What was it like, you were
visiting friends and neighbors.
You catch up with somebody who
went to school with you and it
feels so full circle, it is
crazy.
do you know who this is?
It is Selena Gomez.
My name is Selena.
[laughter]
The one that you hear the songs
of, yeah.
[screaming]
She is my dramatic one.
That is OK.
Yes, she is real, she grew up
down the street from me.
Mommy went to school with her.
Can I have a hug?
Does that make you happy?
Yeah.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
It is good to see you.
I am glad that everything is
good for you, to see you go
through all of that was
inspiring.
Thank you.
I feel better.
We love you.
[applause]
every time I go home I
Usually drive by my old
neighborhood, just because it
feels so good.
It reminds me.
Every time I am home I usually
love going to visit people.
At that time, I invaded peoples
personal space.
I could be disrupting neighbors,
or with my friends, watching her
have children and a totally different life.
Thinking I could have that life,
I am nowhere near that.
It is not a bad thing.
You gave her daughter this
moment, and she gave you genuine
love and concern from someone
you knew long ago.
It was such a lovely human moment.
It was the trade gone right.
When she said she was happy I
was doing well, she means that,
it doesn't matter I've become
whatever.
I am still Selena.
We see a strife for a
different type of purpose.
You found purpose as a young child,
and it was successful
when during the making of the documentary, did you
realize, you were getting to a
new purpose in life?
Getting beyond fame and reaching
for something more substantial?
Perhaps, it was when I was
having downs and I could not
hide them.
Whether the camera was there or
not, I could not get out of my
own head.
I realized those moments would
stop me from creating a great
tour, a good year or a good attitude.
It was affecting me.
I knew we were capturing these
moments, this is real, this is
what people are walking
through, this is bigger than
what we are worried about.
There were multiple moments,
where I thought it would be bigger
than just me.
It begins a really fascinating journey in life when you
realize that you want to go and alter your purpose.
People around you might not
understand what that means.
There is a promo cycle, to be
fair, they happen all of the
time, but you are ready to
announce this even in a small way.
You want to do something bigger,
and it doesn't land.
I looked at your face and it
does not land, I looked at your
face.
This will take a long time.
Exactly.
We celebrate you for the work
that you have been doing.
These mean something to you now.
Can you talk how talk about
how fulfilling it has been to be
in this space?
It feels wonderful.
It started when I was 14 and I
had a single mother come up to
me, they were from Mexico in a
town close to where my family is
from.
She said thank you for being who
you are, they can -- my children
can look at someone on TV who
looks like them.
I did not understand it because
I am who I am.
Then I recognized the
responsibility that I have been
given with my platform, I truly
felt it was bigger than me.
When I had dark moments I would
get back up over and over again,
it was hard to get up, but if I
stood in a fit of pain, I would
be letting you all down.
I could not live with that.
I could not do that.
I had to learn how to do that
myself.
I had to tell people, I cannot
do that right now.
Now I can be the best version of
myself for other people.
You help others do for
themselves.
That is what I'm take -- that is
what I am taking from the next
chapter of your life.
It ends with you making a
commitment to this conversation.
When we met for the first time,
I recognize that you were really
in this documentary.
I felt that and I believe it's
reflected in the conversation we had.
We landed on a subject we are
both passionate about,
increasing awareness around
mental health, and self-help.
We are seeing changes and you
have been instrumental to making
changes happen.
I want to give you a round of
applause for that.
[applause]
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
you have started to do the groundwork.
How has your experience been,
are we going in the right
direction, where are we going?
Do you feel like it's working?
I want to say yes.
I don't mind being a person who
is the voice of mental health,
it is who I am, it is my life, I
want people to become more
comfortable with that
conversation and I want it to
stop being a label that
terrifies people more for people
to stop thinking it is not a
real thing.
If I released this documentary
before the pandemic, they may
have thought I was crazy.
It was interesting to hear,
people react to this movie and
actually say, I did not know I
had that, I struggle with that
as well.
It's no surprise that one of
it is no surprise that one of
your most genuine songs is your most popular.
Now that you understand your
truth better than ever, and have the courage to share it.
We are waiting for the album of your career.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
No pressure.
You set the bar, not me.
I'm just acknowledging it.
If I am being completely
honest, which I have been.
It has been really difficult.
I am used to just making music.
Now I am telling stories about
people, experiences, now I have
to tell these stories and people
will ask a lot of questions.
They will be happy to get
another album.
You didn't have -- you did not
have a choice before.
Everyone decided these were the
stories you needed to tell.
Every artist on the planet gets
To decide how they talk about
The relationship.
You have just caught up to every
artist on the planet.
Thank God.
I feel accomplished.
you can do it your way.
I have earned it.
I do not want to release
anything that is not perfect, it
is getting there.
We are getting to fan questions.
My favorite.
If I could end the rest of my
life asking fan questions.
how does it feel to be your
True and vulnerable self?
I feel like I can relax now.
Now you know everything I was
walking through, you did not
judge me, you were there for me
constantly.
It made me feel normal.
I appreciate that.
What scene in this film are you
most proud of?
Probably when I was
rehearsing for the AMAs  I was
not ready.
I started to listen to a song.
I felt like that was me really
Trying to push through something
That was difficult.
That moment meant more to me.
That was me trying to heal.
It is terrifying to get up and
sing.
It was such a personal
release?
It was, it was such a gift.
Go and look at any
documentary film, the -- there
is not a scene in which Selena
misses a note.
It was great to see you do that.
What was the hardest thing for
You?
probably the tour.
It was really honest.
I had been so inundated with
comments about my body.
There was a reason I was talking
about myself, that way.
I did not make that up.
I had been told that I needed to
look better, dress cooler, my
tour was kinda lame, I was trying to
be someone I was not, that was
happening all of the time, to
me.
I think that is abusive.
I am never going to let anyone
make me feel that way.
I gained my strength back when I
realized, that girl wasn't lame,
was not lame, she did not
need a better body, I am exactly
who I am.
When I was released from the
voice in my life, I did not
fall, I rose up.
That's -- that is the best part.
[applause]
Thank you.
I know there was a longer edit.
for sure.
[LAUGHTER]
that is not even insider
talk, every film has a longer
edit.
Was there anything you wish you
could have gotten in there?
probably more content with my
Fans.
Because the pandemic happened, I
Canceled my tour.
The meet and greets were my only
connection to people.
Me being here is such a high.
I have missed this more than
Anything.
I can wait to meet all of you
and hug you.
Not to put too fine a point
on it, is this the first time in
a long time that you have had
this experience?
Yes, basically.
I am so happy.
It feels good.
How does it feel to know that
you're changing our lives?
and making us feel seen when it
comes to mental health
and this question ends with I love you
I love all of you.
If I am able to help one person
with this, I am on cloud nine.
I hope I am remembered by my
heart.
Simply wanting to see people for
who they are and love them
truly, authentically, and does
purely as possibly I can.
[applause]
In this beautiful Apple Tower
Theatre in downtown Los Angeles,
I want to honor the fact that
you get to see your fans for the
first time in a very long time.
We just came out of the crazy few years.
This would not have been
Possible.
What you went through made it
Seem further away.
I wanted to give you a chance to
Talk to your fans directly And
say something to them.
And we can and like that.
I will end up talking your ear off when I meet you.
Because I like that.
Me releasing this was one of the
most terrifying things that I
have done.
I am so grateful that people
like you are able to watch it,
if a friend is walking through
something, that you are able to
be a voice for them.
I know it is such a cliché, and at
the end of the day it is just me,
my core friends, and us.
I want to continue to be the
best version of myself that I
can and to love you guys fully
and truly for who you are
because you do that for me.
Thank you, so much.
[applause]
♪♪
Watch the film now with your Apple TV+ subscription
on whatever device you stream,
on your Apple TV, MacBook, Smart TVs,
game consoles, connected devices, Roku, or Amazon Fire.
Look for the Apple TV App.
If you do not have it go to the App Store on your device
and download it.